you
[Music]
my name is Anathoth Matty and I am a
professor of finance and economics and
the faculty director of the
corporation's of society initiative
Kassie here at the GSB engaging the GSB
community and others on issues we think
are truly important is a key mission of
Kassie
so I want to welcome all of you and
thank you for joining us and I'd
especially like to thank our panelists
who flew in to participate in this event
I also want to recognize and thank Dean
John Levin for supporting this
initiative and for being here today we
and c-span are videotaping this event so
we hope the conversation will continue
Cathy focuses on governance issues as
they pertain to corporations how do we
ensure that corporations can be trusted
to benefit their stakeholders ultimately
society as a whole without mistreating
deceiving and harming how do we ensure
that governments write appropriate rules
and the corporation's comply with those
rules and what are the roles of among
others employees customers investors
courts and the media in shaping
corporations their culture and their
impact on all of us in October we hosted
John Kerry rue the author of bad blood a
book about fairness mr. kerew said that
one of the grave errors the Eternals CEO
Elizabeth Holmes made was to channel the
fake it til you make it
culture that pervades Silicon Valley but
we have many examples of faking it also
known as fraud in corporate America
whether it takes the form of misleading
investors or customers about your
products opening checking accounts for
customers who didn't ask for them or
falsely tweeting that funding has been
secured for to privatize your company if
corporations have significant power over
customers or employees they can also
harm without breaking the law and if
they have political power they may be
able to write the law or get away with
breaking it successful business leaders
often set lofty goals but we want them
to establish and maintain a culture of
honesty including when adversity and
challenges arise we also want them to
define success properly and avoid blind
spots by doing so there can be better
leaders and they will also likely
prevent legal troubles negative
publicity skeptical investors and public
anger previous Cassie guest Bethany
McLean who wrote the definitive book on
Enron said I think most people in most
companies are extremely well-intentioned
but there is a capability in any company
particularly in a world with short-term
oriented and bottom-line driven to go
wrong some of the subject of today's
conversations have provided almost
weekly examples of how things can go
wrong and with Tesla reporting earnings
its CFO departing and Wells Fargo
releasing a report on its reform process
this week was no exception they shoes
are on cooperation society are complex
we're fortunate to have panelists with
us today panelists with us today with
amazingly rich and varied experiences
and expertise to provide us with some
insight
Fahmy Kadir is a chief investment
officer of SEF ket capital a short only
hedge fund based in New York and founded
in 2017 ms Kadir was featured on the
Netflix series dirty money for her bet
against the troubled drug company
valiant in as an equity analyst at a
hedge fund
KREM savage asset manager management
more recently she has taken a short
position in Tesla among others
Emily glazier is a reporter for The Wall
Street Journal where she now covers
Wells Fargo and JP Morgan Chase from New
York and Los Angeles her reporting on
West Fargo has contributed to public and
political backlash against the bank
remedial actions by regulators in
numerous executive departures and
changes in business practices the bank
has launched multiple publicity
campaigns to regain the public trust
the Honorable Jed Rakoff has been a
federal judge in the US District Court
for the Southern District of New York
for more than 22 years prior to joining
the federal bench Judge Rakoff was a
federal prosecutor in the US Attorney's
Office for the Southern District of New
York for seven years and then spent 16
years as a white-collar criminal defense
lawyers at two large New York firms he
has been unusually outspoken for a judge
and achieved fame for example when he
rejected the settlement between the SEC
and Citigroup and when he called the
settlement between the SEC and Bank of
America half-baked justice following
this conversation will continue
engagement taking questions from our
audience now please join me in thanking
again and welcoming our distinguished
panelists I'm gonna start by engaging
with the panelists and then we'll open
it up so I'm going to ask them each a
question maybe I'll get to the second
one and then maybe all of them a
question we'll see how far we get
depends on the length of the answers
which I hope will be short and to the
point
miss Kadir we teach our students that
managers must focus on maximizing their
company's stock price and also that
public folk up for public cooperation
the stock price provides good signals of
the true value of the corporation equity
as a short seller
you obviously trade on negative
information that others may ignore with
executives wanting to present the
rosiest possible picture disclosures and
statements
how does an investor uncover information
that the corporation wants to obscure
and what beyond trading do you do with
such information thank you or not so the
perennial dilemma of the short seller is
that the same body of evidence the
publicly available information that
management will use to create that rosy
narrative is the same information that I
as a short seller have to use to
disprove the fundamentals of the company
or show that there is evidence of fraud
so that's the starting point so how do
we use that information in a different
way and ultimately for any investor
particularly the skeptical investor it
comes down to asking the right questions
that's really where it all begins
so we're prevent presented with the same
exact information but we are looking at
it with a different point of view and
asking the critical questions so every
investor whether it's a short seller or
a journalist or a skeptical sell-side
analysts you should really listen to
those who are asking the challenging
questions because that will help us see
between the lines of the narrative that
management is trying to create to get
more into the details I typically avoid
earnings reports I like to review the
balance sheet because understanding the
assets and liabilities that's really
what's real about the business and what
we can kind of follow the money trail
but earnings earnings and you know the
income statement the cash flow statement
is subject to a lot of manipulation so
we can we can use that but again it's
it's not gonna provide the kind of
context that we need to understand
what's really going on within the
business and then as a short fund short
fund with not that much capital we need
to be creative about how we use this
information and how we access data and
what kind of data we access so at any
point in time we can assume that there
are billion-dollar funds that have
access to all of the data they can pay
whatever they want to get the credit
card data the satellite data so what can
I do that is different well I can get
away from my computer and I can go out
into the world and I can do real-life
shoe-leather type work field work I can
engage with the customers of the
businesses that I'm looking at former
employees and most critically
whistleblowers again it's about being
creative and gain
that informational edge because you
assume that everyone else has the
quantitative data so it's about
concatenating your not understanding
what management is doing but also how
they behave how they're responding to
those questions and putting that all
together and when we collect that body
of evidence that gives us some
conviction that there's potentially
fraud occurring what do we do with it
well as short-sellers we can't simply
sit on that information because markets
as much as we would like to think are
not particularly efficient so sitting on
undated
is critical to the price discovery of
the stock is not it could lead to me be
going insolvent I could definitely lose
money as the stocks will continue to go
up as the markets will not realize the
fraud so I have to be creative about
disseminating that information so we'll
engage with journalists activists short
sellers and regulators in order to get
the questions out there so investors can
think to themselves this Glaser
corporations often punish explicitly or
implicitly all those who question their
desired narrative journalists have a key
role in exposing gaps between companies
cultivated image and reality how do you
know when to ask more questions and how
do you get answers and how difficult is
it to uncover what's going on and
publish material that powerful
corporations and their leaders do not
want published what role is the need for
access play does the need for access
play so there was a lot that was said
that I would agree with in terms of
journalism I always ask the follow-up
question there are no stupid questions
as much as in my head I think they are
always better to ask them and access
depends on the situation so let's take
Wells Fargo similarly I public
information while very important and
it's extremely important for me to
understand earnings reports I'm not
doing my job if I am sitting in the
office I'm constantly out we call it
sourcing and journalism meeting people
that the company does not really want me
to meet with I certainly take meetings
that are offered to me and that's where
the access part comes in it helps
working at the Wall Street Journal
because we regularly are meeting with
CEOs and other executives and I have
that attached to my name however the
real goods as we like to call it and
when I do my job well is writing about
something that nobody else knows and we
call that scoops scoops are what I live
and die by in many ways and that is
through current and former employees
shareholders a whole variety of them
consultants advisers regulators there
are so many different types of people
that I need to talk to to get a very
clear picture of what's going on because
a company especially on the
communications team they're trying to
paint the most positive picture I think
you said rosy narrative that's a great
way to describe it but if I'm doing my
job as a journalist I need to understand
everything that's going on and there's
often quite a bit but a company might
not want us to know about the other
thing that we need to be wary of
especially with Wells Fargo is that when
someone reaches out to me as a
journalist it's usually extremes it's
like a bad game of telephone sometimes
they either love the company
or they hate the company and I need to
make sure that I can gut check that with
people that I trust so so much of the
reporting with Wells Fargo has been
about cultivating sources over time
figuring out who I can gut-check with
who has a more moderate fair opinion I
hope that my sources will say that's not
true that's going too far
and it really makes me rethink the
information that I'm gathering so that
we can put it out in a fair objective
and accurate way Judge Rakoff
you have prosecuted defended and judged
individuals and corporations on business
and securities fraud cases how well does
our justice system work in a corporate
context where we administer justice to
corporations that produce products we
buy and employ many people there are
laws enable holding executives properly
accountable for conduct given the level
of control they have and how much
deniability especially of intent they
can claim in
so first I want to say it's a real
pleasure to be here
it was hard tearing myself away from the
four degree above zero weather in New
York but here we are the I'm sorry to
have to say that in my view the
prosecution of corporate crime has
significantly deteriorated in the United
States over the last 20 years I start
with the rather obvious point that
inanimate entities like corporations
though themselves commit crimes and his
individuals within the corporation who
make the decisions that lead to criminal
conduct and in the period before 2000
the policy the Department of Justice was
to try to discover exactly who those
people were at the highest possible
level levels of responsibility and that
was very time-consuming required a lot
of resources but frankly was quite
successful and so you had the successful
prosecution of mr. skilling at Enron and
mr. Evers the CEO of worldcom and
Michael Milken in the junk bond scandal
and over 800 people in the Savings and
Loan scandal going all the way up to the
top guy Charles Pedic around 2000 or so
the Justice Department's view changed
the nominal reason that they gave for
the change which was to go after
companies and not after individuals was
that certain companies had
overly aggressive kind of culture and
that if we really wanted to deter
widespread white-collar corporate crime
in the long run we needed to change the
culture of these companies through
compliance measures and the like even on
its face I think that was misguided and
professor Brandon Garrett who has done
the definitive study of all the
corporate prosecutions between 1996 and
2014 has concluded that there was a high
rate of recidivism and much less change
in corporate culture on the part of
those corporations most needing change
and it was hypothesized would occur but
I think really the reason the Department
of Justice changed its policy was
political and also resource management
they when you bring a case against a
company under federal law you can invoke
what's called the doctrine of respondeat
superior which means that the crime of
even the lowest level individual done on
behalf of the corporation can be imputed
to the corporation and so corporations
in the typical case are dead in the
water to begin with they're going to
have to come to a settlement they're
going to have to pay big fines to the
government they're going to have to with
a lot of hoopla say we'll never do it
again and the reason is we've put all
this compliance measures into place and
that's also politically attractive and
you don't have to spend much of
resources and all to realize that result
in theory you could both go after the
corporation and after the individuals in
practice that doesn't happen because it
would be a much more arduous lengthy
process to go after the individuals and
the parkin feels it could achieve enough
I would say politically they might say
in terms of deterrence by going after
just the companies I think this is a
seriously misguided policy ms Khedira
and on CEO skilling famously used
profanity when he was challenged by
short seller on an analyst core lehman
brothers CEO dick fall blamed short
sellers for his bank's failure in ellen
masks
most recently called short sellers value
destroyers and criticized skeptical
analysts bonehead questions how does
this kept achill investor deal with the
hostility from the company and its
cheerleaders well first and foremost
when I see company management going
after journalists or short sellers or
anyone asking the difficult questions
that's a red flag and I'm going to be
digging in so just don't do it but I
think what's most alarming over the past
several years and it's become
progressively more obvious is that the
investment community and that those who
are going long stocks are increasingly
prone to deifying company management and
they can do no wrong so if you ask the
CEO have you committed fraud and he
tells you no I have not you believe them
you don't ask any further questions you
don't even consider the evidence that is
put in front of you because we've our
decision-making has become so dictated
by the stock market and what prices are
doing and we've been in a ten-year bull
market and the prices have just been
going up so we feel that our thesis is
being validated by the price action and
typically yes when you make money you
can say you're right but in this case
the the real asset value is not really
reflected in the price movement so we
can't consider that to be validation so
when we have short sellers or other
skeptics coming forward and asking
questions then we should be listening
because at some point if you are a true
fiduciary
you want to ask responsibly with your
capital or the capital of others then
you need to consider when is the
judicious time to sell and when
someone's asking those tough questions
and you really need to think to yourself
is that almost that time to sell so just
to put this in context of an anecdote I
was i I'm still am short a short term
health insurer and I had made about 50%
on the position already last year and I
attended their Investor day at the end
of last year to assess whether it was
time for me to cover my position I've
made significant profit it seemed almost
cheap on an earnings basis so you know
maybe it was time to walk away so I was
the only short seller that was
apparently there it was difficult to
find out the location of this investor
day because it wasn't disclosed to
anyone who was asking any questions even
the full full investment community
itself and then when I was there I asked
is this investor event being webcast for
the purposes of full disclosure and they
said no it is not so I took out my phone
and I was recording the event so we have
a record and I can distribute that to
investors as they needed the information
and that phone was yeah I was warned
several times aggressively that I was
not allowed to record and that phone was
nearly taken away from me and then
periodically throughout that entire
investor day even though I was sitting
quietly in the back of the room not
asking questions not creating a fuss the
CEO of the company was repeatedly coming
back to me and taunting me bullying me
in an investor on the board had was
passing notes to the CEO giving him
things to say to me including an
invitation to come to the stage in order
to engage in some sort of rap battle I'm
not really sure but throughout the
course of this I'm thinking to myself
okay I didn't realize it was this bad so
maybe it's not time to cover maybe it's
time to double down so really
and in the face if if yeah you have to
think to yourself if you are an invested
in a company and the executive team
decides the best course of action is to
humiliate and engage in ad hominem
attacks against those asking questions
then even if the the skeptic is
incorrect in their assertions is it
really a good sign is a good character
to be engaging in those types of attacks
is that the kind of person you want
running your business and being you know
that the safeguard of your capital I
think not so I think investors who are
long have an obligation to engage with
the skeptics and put pressure on
management they have their voting rights
as a short seller I don't have voting
rights in a company but shareholders do
so when those questions come forward I
think investors need to be much more
cognizant of the questions being asked
and and put much more pressure on
management
thank you miss Glaser we take this issue
very seriously has almost become a
cliche in corporate Public Relation to
respond to reports about scandals scan
some--some yet often they change little
we heard from the judge without pressure
from the outside West Fargo is now
moving to its second post crisis
rebranding instead of reestablished we
now have this as Wells Fargo how
seriously think the issue is of
executives and boards miss diagnosing
diagnosing problems thinking of them is
just public relations problem and that
that's what it's all about and then how
do you as an outside investors sort of
know whether they actually are just
making cosmetic changes are really sort
of changing first I just wanted to
address something that Judge Rakoff
mentioned in terms of sometimes the
settlements and how things shake out and
and what happens from there it reminded
me of covering big banks during a large
foreign exchange settlement in 2015 when
they finally pleaded guilty and the
stock prices went up so just wanted to
mention that
so culture it's this very amorphous
topic and when a company says we're
changing our culture we're doing this
we're doing that we have new ad
campaigns it's very hard for journalists
it's really difficult to write about
something like culture that doesn't have
metrics attached to it all the time
so what I try to look for our specifics
that are actually show change now one of
the things that I noticed with Wells
Fargo was right from the start and for
several months after their top
executives said we do not have a culture
problem everything is great here it's a
certain part of the bank they're
different our CEO is from the wholesale
part of the bank's you never touch
retail bank that was the new person they
brought in to change and from there we
saw problem after problem after problem
I thought my job would calm down after a
little while in fact when I started
covering big banks JP Morgan Chase and
Wells Fargo I was told focus 70ish
percent on JP Morgan 30% ashore so on
Wells Fargo that obviously was changed
dramatically and I thought things would
calm down you know the September 2016
scandal reported non-stop for a couple
months and then we thought okay we're
coming out of the woods but then more
and more and more happened and that
leads you to question what is going on
with the culture what I can say is right
now I do listen to what the executives
say and a big big comment coming from
the CEO timothy sloan of wells fargo and
the chief financial officer john
Shrewsbury is that these are legacy
problems when the federal reserve
slapped Wells Fargo with an
unprecedented enforcement action tapping
the banks growth in February actually
was a year ago how time flies in
February 2018 the bank made it very
clear these are old issues nothing is
new same happen when the OCC the Office
of the Comptroller of the currency and
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
had a settlement with the bank for 1
billion dollars nothing is new these are
old legacy problems I did make a little
cheat sheet of some new problems that
I've written about that happened in 2017
and 2018 and so I'm constantly
during our these old problems employees
added Social Security numbers and other
customer financial personal information
when they were doing anti money
laundering
controls and checks that happen in 2017
and 2018 we just heard about a
regulatory warning to the bank about
their technology oversight for more than
two dozen open regulatory warnings known
as matters requiring attention that's
from 2018
their wealth management problems which
we wrote about definitely cover 2017
that investigation is also still open
I should add the Department of Justice
is investigating the AML issues OCC
mtech foreign exchange problems that
happen through 2017 so I could keep
going
but that all leads me to think how much
is the culture changing what is new and
what is old why are the scripted
responses still the same and for a
journalist it makes me want to keep
probing and keep asking the questions
and when they say they're taking the
issue seriously I just look at the facts
right Judge Rakoff lawyers and
consultants now seem to have taken
responsibility to investigate diagnose
problems and propose remedies these are
in the private sector you describe the
ecosystem as an attempt to rehabilitate
the company's culture the investigations
and reports by Wells Fargo Bank one
example and overseeing settlements also
outsource to lawyers and consultants
what's your view of how well this system
of corporations investigating and
rehabilitating themselves work does this
process serve the interests of
shareholders and the broader goal of
justice in a corporate context so I
first want to say that I do not want to
comment about Wells Fargo and nothing I
say should be taken as reflective of
that under federal law precluded from
commenting on any matter that is still
in any respect ongoing and in any event
with Emily here I don't need to comment
the the corporate prosecution approach
that I described before has proven very
lucrative to certain institutions or
organizations all of course at the
expense of shareholders who virtually
always have nothing to do with the
underlying misconduct so whereas in the
old days prosecutors and people at the
SEC and so forth would undertake arduous
lengthy difficult investigations of
alleged corporate malfeasance now what
happens is that the prosecutor will lay
a subpoena on the company having heard
about some problem and the company will
have a outside counsel almost always a
former prosecutor from the very same
office come visit and say we're prepared
to investigate this we want to do the
right thing we want to cooperate don't
feel you need to spend any time or money
on this we will get you the answers
we'll do a thorough investigation and
report back to you in six or nine months
with the results and it's very hard for
the prosecutor to say no to that offer
those are very lucrative assignments I'm
told that in the Siemens case the total
investigation netted fees to de boys and
plimpton of three billion dollars the
if you want to know why they hire Mary
Jo white now you know they but that's
just the start because after the council
comes back and says oh we've cleaned up
our act
council will almost always propose a
bunch of new compliance measures to
create a better culture and make sure
that this never happens again and the
government will maybe up the ante and
say no that's not enough we need still
further compliance measures and that's a
very expensive proposition it typically
exists over several years involves
people both hired by the company and
people from outside who the company has
to pay for and all of this again comes
out of the pockets of the innocent
shareholders so there is a strong
economic motive pushing this kind of
approach and yet to repeat what I
mentioned earlier the all the most
careful studies suggest that it doesn't
accomplish that much there are cases
Pfizer is the sort of poster child here
Pfizer went through four different
deferred prosecution agreements and
broke each one of them each time
announcing that oh today we put in place
compliance measures that will prevent us
from ever doing anything wrong again and
when finally the government had no
choice but to bring a full-fledged
prosecution they rightly were concerned
about the fact that they didn't want to
put Pfizer out of business which would
have been very unfair to not only the
shareholders but to the many employees
who had nothing to do with the
misconduct and so the actual guilty plea
was entered by a shell subsidiary of
Pfizer
that only the shell was put out of
business and not the company as a whole
and these are the kinds of dilemmas you
face when you go down this road as
opposed to if you were going after a
high-level executive no company is going
to fold because a high-level executive
was prosecuted and went to jail and yet
the deterrent effect on other high-level
executives of his or her going to jail
is in my view quite substantial I'm
gonna ask just a couple more questions
of of the whole panel anybody who wants
to respond Wells Fargo's board report
described former CEO John Stumpf is it
by nature and optimistic executive and
Ken Lay from Enron was also described as
optimistic attack what's the line
between naive optimism and willful
blindness the desire by executives not
to see or hear about problems just if
that's conveying an implicit message
that people should cover up problems and
not bring him up so how do people then
in watchdogs and board some of this was
covered by your previous answer struck
the right balance between skepticism and
this optimism I don't think that
skepticism and optimism are two
different sides of the coin I think
they're they're the exact same thing if
in order to believe in the long-term
prospects of a company you need to be
skeptical about what management is doing
and I think we at this point in history
face this problem where investors seem
to equate the success of the business to
the success of the executive and we are
too dependent on the CEO founders I
think this is probably due to the rise
of technology companies in Silicon
Valley where we expect that that CEO
founder to have all of the power within
the company as far as dis making the
decisions and there are no checks and
balances and we applaud those executives
when they surround themselves with
employees that are
yes men with boards that are yes men and
no one really wants to take
accountability anymore it's really down
to you know whatever the executive wants
because he or she is a genius that they
are the best suited to make decisions
for a publicly traded organization which
i think is terribly unwise so I think we
need to return to a time where all of
those individuals whether the the
auditors the members of the board the
investors they all need to realize what
are their separate duties in this
financial system and and they need to to
not act as pawns of the executive
management but really they need to act
independently and take accountability
for the decisions that are made because
ultimately if the executive makes
fraudulent decisions then everyone's
going down I would just add two quick
points to that I think experience is
necessary but when you surround
yourselves with the same people year in
and year out whether management or the
board you're not getting fresh
perspective I'll bring it back to Wells
Fargo so did a little math on the train
ride over here or looked at some numbers
on the proxy I should say and they're
2016 proxy which covered the 2015 year
there were nine directors on their board
that served between five and fifteen
years that's a very long tenure you need
to have a lot of they call you know
fresh blood on the board and the bank
has since added I believe six new
directors since the scandal kind of
became public
they also touted and a lot of companies
do this as well I shouldn't just say
Wells Fargo covered Procter & Gamble
when an activist investor came in
Herbalife what an activist investor came
in some other companies this insular
culture of Management that have served
20 plus years together and grown up
together and if you aren't bringing in
outsiders who are really questioning the
status quo and you have what turns into
yes-man without even realizing it that's
when these problems can just continue
growing even without people noticing it
so I'm not sure it's a question of
optimism or pessimism as a American I am
of course a born optimist as a Jew I am
of course a born pessimist
but the doctrine the legal doctrine of
conscious disregard willful disregard
requires that you intentionally close
your eyes to what is there to be seen
it's not just that you're often a cloud
and and you should be more down-to-earth
it requires that you purposely say I
don't want to hear that or Joe you take
care of that don't tell me about it
the my experience as a prosecutor was
that this was extremely common at high
levels in certain areas a lot of
accounting fraud I think fits that kind
of situation but that's what's required
and the government cannot either
criminally or even civilly succeed on a
willful disregard conscious disregard
theory unless they can show that you
purposely turned your self away from
what was there clearly to be seen my
final question to the whole panel
it was the LA Times and not any
regulator a prosecutor that broke the
Wells Fargo account scandals the Federal
Reserve took almost 17 months after the
full scope of the scandal became public
to take any action and that's a key
regulator for bank holding companies for
Tesla alone Musk has repeatedly insulted
the SEC both before and after settling
securities fraud charges with them
various media reports about unsafe
working conditions in Tesla just
recently resulted in California issuing
six citations for fine of $30,000 our
regulator is doing their jobs what
messages are these agencies sending to
the market and to the public with these
action or lack of action well it's
increasingly
alarming that we live in a world where
regulations are being rolled back key
organizations that protect consumers and
the public are being disarmed and
investors are sort of just standing by
and allowing it to occur and regulators
again are almost rolling over there
they're under-resourced and they're
there's so much fraud in the markets how
do you even have the time to spend to
prosecute and do you have enough
evidence to be able to prosecute for
criminal corporate behavior and it's a
it's an increasingly difficult job so
nothing is more effective than the court
of public opinion and as a short seller
you know I found we interact with
regulators but it'll often take years
for them to even initiate investigations
and they will send all of our work and
they'll collect thousands and thousands
of pages of documents evidencing crime
and potential fraud but they can't do
anything and I'm not sure whether it's
because they simply can't or if there's
some element of regulatory capture but
at least with journalists you can
publicly shame these companies and
objectively inaccurately and then the
the average person who's reading these
articles is then better aware investors
are better aware and they can make more
judicious financial decisions and
consumer decisions but but just this
week so so we are short a company called
wire card based out of Germany
and the Financial Times has come out
with a series of incredible
investigative reports this week
indicating fraud and criminal
money-laundering
at this German bank wire card and within
minutes of the publications coming out
the company itself comes out saying that
the reports are defamatory denying all
claims and then within less than a day
of those reports coming out the German
public prosecutor comes out and says
that they don't believe there to be any
wrongdoing occurring at what at this
company wire card and then shortly after
that boffin the German securities
regulator says they are launching a
market manipulation
probe into the trading around wirecolor
so in the US I think we haven't reached
that point of regulatory capture but I
think there needs to be faith restored
in our regulation and the corporate
system because we just simply aren't
seeing corporate prosecutions anymore
and there's no moment of comeuppance
where these these executives are engaged
in such high levels of crime investors
aren't holding them to account the
justice system isn't holding to the
account so who is I would just add a
couple quick points I'm feeling you
might want to respond to that but um our
regulators doing their jobs yes they
still are I think sometimes the amounts
of the fines especially over the years
can really dictate how much attention is
given when Bank of America paid a
sixteen point six five billion dollar
fine it was the largest of the time
related to crisis era problems that kind
of set this number with Wells Fargo
they've paid about four billion so far
collectively till since 2016 are their
problems better or worse than Bank of
America and the mortgage crisis I'll let
you guys decide I mean my job is
presenting the information and doing it
in a fair and accurate way however what
I will say is there are a lot of
outstanding issues I think you mentioned
before how long some of these
investigations take Tesla for instance
is still under criminal investigation so
while there was a thirty thousand dollar
settlement pennies to these companies
I'm curious what might happen with the
criminal investigation with Wells Fargo
there's still an open and pretty
multifaceted Department of Justice and
SEC separate investigations going going
on so we have to wonder okay what will
happen there and I think sometimes
regulators try to self-correct a little
bit when you mentioned the sizer example
before Judge Rakoff it did remind me a
little bit of Wells Fargo which had this
ongoing dialogue with the Fed and the
OCC about fixing its risk management
system which is how it's supposed to
find and prevent problems they kept
going back and forth again and again
extended deadlines submit extended
deadlines oh we're not going to fail you
but we're giving you
language that might make you realize
that you need to resubmit the risk
framework this has gone on and on and on
the risk framework is still not approved
by the way this is many years later so
it's not quite the same as a deferred
prosecution agreement but how much
give-and-take is there the Fed finally
had this unprecedented enforcement
action and really showed its strength
there right on Janet yellen's last day
so I think we have to give the
regulator's credit it's how long it
takes what happens and sometimes the
amount of the fine that helps us
understand the context around it so I
had a conversation about a week ago with
Jeff Berman the US Attorney for the
Southern District of New York he
probably thought this was a private
conversation but in the confidence of
the c-span broadcast I will relay it he
was complaining that he that the US
Attorney's Office was receiving fewer
criminal referrals from the SEC than in
prior years by the way both he and I
have a great respect for the SEC and
there are a hundred different reasons
this might have occurred so I don't want
to make too much out of it but I said to
him well what are you going to do about
it he said oh I've already taken a step
I have arranged for each member of the
fraud unit that's the unit that
prosecutes these matters to receive each
morning a copy of The Wall Street
Journal so I did not give that Judge
Rakoff any financial an exchange in this
panel okay I wanted our leave time 15
minutes or a little more than that to
audience questions so please raise your
hand unfortunately we do not need mics
so you can just go ahead and speak but
spirit please my name is mike mizrahi
GSB students here in the MSX program
but I wanted to ask you this question
and it's more of a system questioners
this is the possibility of getting us a
settlement with the SEC without without
admitting or denying guilt incentivize
the companies to sort of make it in as
cost of doing business so this policy
goes back to the 1970s I think it's a
misguided policy but let me tell you
what its rationale is the it arose in
the context of the Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act problem before there was a
statute most American are many American
companies we're paying bribes and the
SEC said we think that was a violation
of the securities laws because you
didn't disclose it so there was a
failure to disclose but we will we sort
of understand that Congress had not yet
acted at the time you did this so we
will allow you to settle without
admitting or denying and the reason that
was important to the company and the
reason it's still important to company
is class actions they do not want to be
in the position of having admitted
something that will then lead to their
being as we say in the law collaterally
estopped from denying it in the
corresponding class action so it's all
about class actions and the very large
exposure that they typically will find
in a class action the SEC goes along
with it because it makes settlements so
much easier and so it's just a again a
resource saving mechanism for them the
problem I have with it is that no one
ever knows the truth so here you have
the SEC and their complaint saying they
did all sorts of bad things here you
have the company not omitting or denying
in the old days the next day they would
issue a press release saying we deny but
we were going we set
because it was a cost of doing business
the sec then put in a gag rule which
i've also criticises I think perhaps
violative of the First Amendment where
you can no longer if you're the company
you don't have to admit anything but you
can't deny it after you sign these deals
so I'm told I don't know if this is true
that what company now do does is they
leak the denial to the Wall Street
Journal but the the public in these very
important cases has an interest they
knowing what the truth is and the effect
of these settlements is that you never
know what the truth is now settlements
are a good thing in as a general matter
but there are cases in cases and the
when an important claim is made by a
government agency that you committed
massive fraud that has costs investors
and the public generally millions even
billions of dollars and the public never
knows whether that was a fair accusation
or an unfair accusation that I think is
not a good way to proceed
whether executive compensation and the
nature of it the size of it see the
methodology of it at whether it's
formulaic or not is a huge early warning
signal and the sorts of problems of
fraud and misrepresentation and
destruction of value that you talk about
I'll take a first stab at that I think
it's a great question
what we've seen and this really goes
back to corporate governance and the
role of the board in many cases because
they are dictating how management top
management are paid and at large
companies that's millions if not tens of
millions of dollars what we've seen
especially in the banking industry
is that there are more and more often
CEOs or c-level executives are paid in
performance shares that vest over time
usually a couple of years at least
what I've seen with Wells Fargo and I do
want to give them credit where credit is
due it came up in the report that was
more than a hundred pages released
earlier this week is that they have
significantly changed how they
compensate executives clawbacks are also
key with companies sometimes they're
public sometimes they're private I love
writing about them when they're private
I think it's very interesting to find
out how much money was clawed back from
executives that happened with JPMorgan
Chase in the London whale the head of
the Investment Office was clawed back
significant amounts of her compensation
at Wells Fargo they've had I want to get
this number right tens of millions of
dollars I'll be on the safe side in
clawbacks but I know there are more
private ones that I'm still trying to
figure out and another way that
compensation has also changed comes back
to companies adding a risk management
component in performance evaluations I
think this is key because a lot of times
these scandals as you know the media
likes to call them but these are very
serious issues sometimes fraudulent will
come up and an executive has already
been paid and then retires it just
leaves and so we did notice that with
Wells Fargo as well and in part because
of the regulator the Office of the
Comptroller of the currency there has
been a limitation on golden parachutes
so if you just retire and leave and if
you haven't been fired you can't just
get millions and millions of dollars
anymore I would only add one thing which
is while you are right the compensation
is a major component of this mix other
changes can often be equally or of
greater significance for example when I
was a kid bankers were sort of you know
the sleepy eyed people of the of the
world
very conservative and then
glass-steagall was repealed and the
bankers became
as a class much more aggressive because
they were really in a different kind of
business so the changes like that could
also be important following up on the
last question
harkening back to the Disney case when
Michael Eisner fired Michael Ovitz
for very poor performance over the
course of a year and he walked away with
140 million dollars in severance which
20 years ago was actually big money and
and the case were led to a suit in the
Delaware Chancery Court and I want to
ask about the role of the judge if he's
in these types of litigation because the
judge there wrote an opinion saying well
Eisner has come forward and said there
was no basis for denying him the
compensation because we could the fire
him for cause even though there was
spectacular evidence in the trial that
obits had repeatedly lies of documentary
evidence and Sid Bassett was a 25%
shareholder of Disney at the time
rehearsed many of these lies and the
judge ignored it all had said you know
Eisner has come forward and said there
was no basis for termination for cause
and that's how the case then and then a
different judge I think would have at
least highlighted all of the evidence of
dishonesty and I think sending a message
to the corporate world that dishonestly
will be disregarded as a dangerous
message
well I certainly don't want to comment
on whether the judge got it right or
wrong in that case the the court of
Dylan recorder of Chancery a very
important court in corporate matters is
unusual in the anglo-american setup
because it's not a jury situation it's a
it's a judge who's making most of the
factual determinations whereas in most
cases in most courts of the United
States it's the jury that makes the
final determinations also something that
is somewhat unique to the anglo-american
system which is that factual findings
are subject to very limited review on
appeal for they can only be reversed for
clear error whereas in most European
systems a higher court can say we've
looked at the record and we just don't
agree and and we come out this all the
facts differently than the lower court
so I think there is built into our
system perhaps too much deference to the
district courts of the lower courts I
say that of course the big exception
being my decisions but I think that
there is a little bit of an
institutional problem there but I can't
comment on the specific case
Chancery costs $20 just a source for a
case I'll get a document which I realize
is not your court
but what can actually be done in the
Southern District of New York today
right now to start to reverse that trend
is there anything
are there any pilot projects because I
look I don't see a whole lot going on
and we all kind of know the situation
that we're in but it seems what is going
on well I think you're raising more than
one question there if your assertion is
that the courts are biased in favor of
companies I actually don't think that's
true but if what you're talking about is
access to the courts that's a huge
problem but it's much more a problem on
for everyday folks having everyday legal
problems the the problem here is that
the legal profession which we call it a
profession but it's actually
economically a cartel has priced itself
out of the price range that most
Americans can afford and the statistics
are really quite shocking in family
court in the housing court which are the
two courts that everyday Americans most
get involved in sooner or later over
two-thirds of the individuals are not
represented by lawyers at all
they're they make enough so that they
can be given appointed lawyers but they
don't make enough to actually afford a
lawyer they lose cases in those two
courts at a 500 percent greater rate
that people who are represented by
lawyers so it makes its case is positive
in most cases my own I think there are
two solutions
for certain basic legal things I think
online legal services is is definitely a
something that can improve this
situation I would like to see in the
legal profession what are the equivalent
in the medical area of nurse
practitioners legal technicians who
wouldn't require three years of law
school I don't think you need three
years of law school anyway and but would
have a certain amount of training and a
certain apprenticeship and then could do
basic skills like go into Family Court
and to house in court I represent them
that's a different point than what
you're talking about but it is I think
maybe this one of the single greatest
legal problems in the United States one
last question
worked at the CFPB as well as for a
bunch of large financial players and so
my question is some of the stories that
we probably don't hear about are those
situations where these types of scandals
and difficult decisions we learn about
in the classroom are actually handled
well and I'm wondering if from your
perspectives and you have any examples
of where executives are actually
approaching these from what you think
are particularly responsible actions in
the face of very difficult decisions and
those are stories we have seen or those
that don't come up that we don't get to
see I'll use Wells Fargo as an example
because there have been a number of
different problems that have come open
in different ways and I think in the two
years and roughly four months since the
sales practice those problems occurred
they have changed the way that they
acknowledge problems come forth with
what they are are not doing and engage
and are trying to be more transparent so
I think you can see companies evolve
over time especially when they're on the
hot seat I have to keep thinking about
companies that have done very well I'll
come back to you on that I don't know if
either of you can weigh in well I want
to say a more general thing which is I
think is beyond
that American business people as a whole
are far more artists than in a great
many countries in the world and I just
had a case that settled a few months ago
called in Ray Petrobras which was a
class action based on what had occurred
in Brazil and the corruption there was
just endemic throughout not just the
company itself but other companies who
were suppliers the government of Brazil
the whole thing was just totally corrupt
from top to bottom you don't see that in
the United States thank God so we have
lots of problems which we've been
discussing but I don't want to neglect
to put this in the broader perspective
that American Bisset people as a whole I
think have much to be proud of and to
follow on the judges comments I think a
lot of that has to do with corporate
transparency in the United States I
think the reporting requirements in the
u.s. is much more stringent than outside
of the u.s. at least at the public
company level but there there have been
movements now within the SEC to question
whether or not we need quarterly
reporting but I think investors need to
really press and and ask ask the
companies that they're invested with for
more information and when questions do
arise judicious companies and they they
do exist some you know not all companies
that commit fraud are doing so
intentionally sometimes you're between a
rock and a hard place your fundamentals
are deteriorating you're in the business
you know a difficult business cycle so
you'll bring in outsiders to investigate
the company and then you you actually
will make that report public to your
investors so they can then assess
whether or not the problems are resolved
so again it really comes down to
transparency in the United States which
is again much greater than the rest of
the world I want to thank you all for
being here thanks for the panel
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]